[Musik]
so sieht er sich gerne ein macher der
anpackt armin laschet will bundeskanzler
werden und die drängendsten probleme
unserer zeit lösen klimaschutz
beispielsweise das wird das thema der
zwanziger jahre werden
ich will dass unser land klimaneutral
wird nicht mit bürokratie wenn wir so
arbeiten wie wir bisher arbeiten werden
wir die ambitiösen klimaziele nicht
erreichen man müsste das jetzt anpacken
ich sage das mache ich anpacken ist
bitter nötig auch in loschwitz
bundesland im arnsberger wald große
flächen sind hier vernichtet opfer von
trockenheit und borkenkäfer die toten
bäume mussten gefällt werden
die waldbauern sind verzweifelt nun wir
haben hier größere waldflächen mit
katastrophalen folgen mein sohn
überlegte ich ob er überhaupt das erbe
antreten will weil er weiß dass er
daraus niemals geld verdienen kann
doch die waldbauern haben hoffnung
wollen windräder auf den kahlen flächen
errichten
so könnten sie geld verdienen für die
wiederaufforstung durch den kahlschlag
hier durch die aufforstung haben die
lokalbesitzer keine einnahmen in den
nächsten 30 bis 50 jahren und in
windkraft würde helfen diesen zeitraum
zu überbrücken und dem wald sicher und
vernünftigen umzuformen in mischwald in
die windkraft dazu beitragen dass ich
wieder aufpassen kann ja natürlich
das können wir so nicht finanzieren doch
der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen haben ihr laschet
will keine windräder im wald aus
opposition zu den grünen machte er schon
im landtagswahlkampf 2017 stimmungen
gegen neue windräder auch geld verdient
es nicht die caritas wer windräder
aufstellt da wird auch ein bisschen geld
verdient in dieser branche windräder im
wald aufstellen das hatte die rot-grüne
vorgängerregierung ermöglicht doch armin
laschet machte das wieder rückgängig mit
einem eigenen erlass und der gilt selbst
dann wenn vom wald nichts mehr übrig ist
politik von alaska sagt röhrs für dieses
land uns fehlt die vision der
erneuerbaren energien als ersatz für die
althergebrachten energien werden nur von
dieser landesregierung neue erlasse die
zur verhinderung führt auch eine
bürgerinitiative will den windpark
verhindern unterstützt von friedrich
merz der in der nähe wohnt begründung
den wald schützen und den seltenen
schwarz durch das ist ein vorwand sagt
dirk jansen
er ist von beruf naturschützer der
schwarzstorch brauche gesunden wald zum
brüten
also er brütet der faktor in der nähe
aber sie sind ja hier das ist potenziell
für die nächsten 30 40 50 60 jahre
sicherlich keinen bruder habitat mehr
artenschutz ist ein wichtiger belang
auch bei der planung von
windenergieanlagen aber viele
bürgerinitiativen instrumentalisieren
den artenschutz missbrauchen den
schwarzstorch um solche planungen zu
verhindern
der zubau mit der windkraft in nordrhein
westfalen läuft schleppend
nur 390 megawatt im schnitt pro jahr
unter ministerpräsident laschet viel zu
wenig um die klimaschutzziele der
bundesregierung 2030 zu erreichen müsste
sich das tempo mehr als verdreifachen
auf 1270 megawatt pro jahr in der nähe
der westfälischen stadt soest
hier will michael flocke die windkraft
weiter ausbauen
seine vier windräder sind fast 20 jahre
alt und erreichen das ende ihrer
laufzeit
anstelle der vier alten windräder sollen
zwei moderne kommen die dann das
doppelte an wind strom produzieren
eigentlich ein guter plan das problem
laschets landesregierung will ein neues
gesetz neue windräder sollen einen
abstand von mindestens 1000 meter zur
wohnbebauung einhalten wenn der
gesetzesentwurf so kommt wie in letzten
fassung vorliegt werden diese beiden
anlagen sehr wahrscheinlich nicht
errichtet werden können weil eben diese
1000 meter abständen in gänze nicht
eingehalten werden können dh es gibt
hier noch windpark nein dann wird das
einzigste windvorranggebiet in soest im
stadtgebiet so ist verschwinden so wie
in vielen anderen kommunen auch diese it
experten haben alle wind standorte in
nordrhein-westfalen analysiert auch den
von windmüller flocke mit lasches
abstandsregel bleibt für flocke nur eine
winzige fläche übrig durch die auch noch
ein wirtschaftsweg führt das aus für die
geplanten anlagen das gleiche droht
tausenden windrädern wenn nazis
abstandsregel gesetz wird könnten 85
prozent aller windräder nicht erneuert
werden
das haben die it experten für jede
einzelne anlage berechnet mit diesem
neuen gesetzentwurf kann man auch für
die zukunft sagen dass eigentlich der
zubau der windenergie praktisch zum
erliegen kommen wird und das entspricht
absolut nicht den klimapolitischen
zielen die sich nrw selber gesetzt hat
und dieses auch zu erfüllen hat das
heißt ziel verfehlt das heißt wenn der
gesetzentwurf so kommt sie verfehlt
doch armin laschet sieht bei der
windkraft keine probleme im gegenteil es
gebe sogar einen aufwärtstrend und der
halter an schriftlich lässt laschet
erklären
zitat die landesregierung treibt gerade
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
erfolgreich voran
auch im bereich photovoltaik liegt
nordrhein-westfalen an der spitze
spitze bei einem solarzellen super
tatsächlich hat nrw seit löws
amtsantritt pro einwohner 54 weniger
solarzellen installiert als der rest von
deutschland
dabei hat laschet landesregierung vor
zwei jahren eine solaroffensive
gestartet für landeseigene gebäude mit
dem naturschützer dirk jansen schauen
wir in der landeshauptstadt düsseldorf
nach was von dieser offensive auf den
gebäuden des landes zu sehen ist
das ist die staatskanzlei hier residiert
armin laschet und wir sehen dass man
nicht sehen in sachen photovoltaik das
wirtschaftsministerium steht direkt dort
nehmen da sind antennen offenen dach
aber in sachen erneuerbare energien
photovoltaik sieht man weder was auf dem
dach noch an den fassaden
frauenministerium ist ein stück weiter
hier rechtsschwenk hier unten das flache
gebäude wäre natürlich ideal hier um
hier pv-anlagen aufs dach zu knallen und
wir sehen gar nicht das land besitzt
rund 4300 gebäude und auf diesen sind
während laschet amtszeit nach frontal21
recherchen gerade einmal 18 solaranlagen
in betrieb gegangen
also die regierung laschet hat weder
eine solare baufläche verankert noch
regularien zum bau von zb freiflächen pv
anlagen entlang vorbelasteter
infrastruktur trassen wie autobahnen
insofern sind wir in sachen photovoltaik
ausbau trotz der enormen potenziale noch
entwicklungsland
der kanzlerkandidat der union sieht sich
selbst als macher der anpackt beim
klimaschutz
armin laschet hat angekündigt er wolle
deutschland so regieren wie sein eigenes
bundesland
[Musik]